the jurogan experience so what about
uh i like can we talk about river
mexican
yeah sure so it's i covered it what they
did in mexico city
and ivermectin seems to be a drug that
not only treats it
but it will prevent you from getting it
i think we need studies we need
legitimate studies
and uh i don't know how that happens
because the problem with this argument
this conversation is
you know you'll you'll have people
saying i've used this
on my patients like dr pierre corey who
has been on this podcast
and i 100 believe him and i support him
and i'm not saying
he's not telling the truth the problem
is i think in order to state something
emphatically like this is what we need
to do this is the best treatment we need
studies
right this is the only way you find out
and well who's going to fund this
understanding and the problem is it's a
generic drug that's it no it's a drug
that's been around for 40 years has a
long history of use
and also there's a difference between
using it as a prophylactic so using it
as a preventative measure which is one
of the things that
dr pierre corey talked about on this
podcast i forget where they used this
but it was uh
this there was hundreds of doctors and
then there was a percentage of them that
used uh ivermectin as a prophylactic and
there's a percentage that did not
the percentage did that did not half of
the doctors roughly or half of the
healthcare workers
got coveted the percentage that did use
it as a prophylactic
100 percent did not get it now
i don't know if they got lucky this is
why you need a large study
and it's a long-term study maybe i don't
know what
was their job different than the people
who got it i don't know
that's the problem yeah so when i'm
talking i'm a [ __ ] comedian and a
cage fighting commentator
and i'm talking about very important
issues i have to hedge
my opinions on these things know right
it's tricky
but it in a but in an environment where
people aren't allowed to talk or
question things
you know um well for instance um
my doctor so when i uh i got the vaccine
i got to double
and which one did you get i got the
moderna because i have an underlying
health problem
i don't want and i've talked about
before we all talked about it yeah
and uh so my doctor because my people
are like why did you
you trust the government i know i don't
trust the government you trust big
pharma no
i don't trust big pharma i trusted my
doctor right my doctor who saved my life
and said that because of your thing you
should get it because we don't know how
it's going to affect you and you
blah blah blah so i got it and then you
know i just the
you know the symptoms you get from it uh
they never went away
for me what were your symptoms so i had
uh
body aches flu-like fever uh i had
joint pain i had a stiff neck
have you tried going in an ice bath for
20 minutes
sorry yeah yeah how long did it yeah
it's still cold
i'm just warming up now i could tell
is uh when you how long did it last
how long do your symptoms last so on on
april 17th i got the second jab
and i just never got better was it
immediate before this
the after the first jab did you have
side effects yes but they went away
and then the second jab how long did
they last after the first shot i don't
remember
because a couple days yeah it was like
maybe a week
i think a week and um and then the
second time they just never went away
and i was like what is going on because
i would get these waves of exhaustion
a couple times a day and then my
producer had the same
stuff after at the fifth week i had a
stiff neck he got a stiff neck and my
wife got a stiff neck
and we all got the stiff neck on the
side where we got the shot so i got it
on this side
they got it on that side and then i
looked it up and it turns out stiff neck
is a thing that people
experience from the jab and i was like i
didn't know that they don't tell you
that
and so that's common i'm like okay and
then it spread to the whole neck
okay now my producer and my wife it went
away their stiff necks went away mine
didn't
so anyway so i go to so i i tweeted
about it i tweeted like hey this is just
let everybody know
this is what's happened this is my
reaction to the vaccine yeah
and because uh when people started to
come on me like call me anti-vaxx and
you're i'm like no i got the vacs
i got it i go when people have a
reaction to an experimental vaccine that
is not fda approved
you're supposed to not suppress the
reactions you're supposed to
ask people what the reactions are so we
could make the vaccines better
that's a thing that when jen saki's
talking about
misinformation online and combating
misinformation
she distributed misinformation of course
because she said that it's approved by
the fda in their gold standard she said
that she said that
it is not approved when you go to get
the vaccine pull up pull it
pull that up let's make sure that she
said i'm 99 positive she said that
because i remember reading that going
you can't say that when you're
the white house press secretary because
that's not a true statement this is
it's approved for emergency use
authorization
because we're in the middle of a
pandemic right that's an emergency yes
but it's not an fda approved joe when
you go get this jab
they give you a piece of paper and on it
in bold black letters it says this is
not an fda approved
vaccine right and they think you see
that and i'm like
yeah they go uk with that yeah i guess
my doctor said
i'm supposed to be here and sign it yeah
i found the
transcript of it i didn't find the video
well okay
i'm pretty sure i saw the video but i
definitely have read the transcript and
i want this to be
accurate because it's a big accusation
this is what she said here when someone
asked about the mystery
what is this from whitehouse.gov okay um
so you know more than just a competition
about vaccines risk impact
uh okay here it is um misleads the
public by falsely alleging that mrna
vaccines are untested and thus risky
even though
many of them are approved and have gone
through the gold standard of the fda
approval process
that's right that's not true so she's
saying many of the mrna vaccines right
there's only two
that are mrna vaccines that's messenger
rna that is the pfizer
and the moderna that's the ones that we
use in america
um the johnson johnson is it's an
adinovirus
vaccine it's different as is the
astrazeneca right
the astrazeneca i believe is very
similar to the johnson and johnson
they're different but the point is yeah
the johnson johnson uses the old
technology
and the modern and pfizer they use the
ones that was developed by darpa
yeah but the point is it's like it's not
fda approved yes no because that takes a
while
so if she's saying that right this is
is that misinformation it is it seems
like it and it's if it says it
when you get the jab and it says it in
bold print
and you so your experience even though
you you this is your personal experience
and you did get vaccinated
people are so rabid online oh my god
it is the most divisive subject i think
ever since trump
it really is it is a nutty divisive
subject
and people just get furious about it and
they're furious if
anybody talks about any negative side
effects even if it's accurate
i know so so i i had tweeted about it
just because i was i want to see if
other people have this experience
and you know maybe it's just me maybe
it's not
so i got contacted by lots of people
same experience and i got contacted by a
doctor who's leading a bunch of other
doctors a group of doctors and studying
this and they just
submitted a paper on people about the
vaccine
right and so uh
he tells me over at dm this is what we
think is happening
this is a spiked protein you're
suffering from a spike protein thing and
blah blah blah
and go to see your doctor and hopefully
your doctor will work
with us and give me ivermectin and
fluvoxamine i'm taking for inflammation
in my brain
you have inflammation in your brain well
that's because it causes inflammation
so the spike proteins cause inflammation
and so they did some kind of blood test
on me and they said yeah you got the
thing
was it a d dimer test is that what it
was joe you got me but
they said you look you're you are you
have the same you're right
where a long haul coveted person is like
whatever the markers were i had the same
thing you're right there
and so might i go to my doctor and i'd
start to explain to my doctor
about what this other doctor told me and
my doctor says oh i'm treating five
people
just like you and one of them is a
neurosurgeon and one of them is a nurse
and they were afraid to talk about their
symptoms because they were afraid to be
ostracized and stigmatized
and i'm like what a messed up strange
situation we're in in this culture right
when they politicize medicine where
doctors and medicine medical
professionals are afraid to talk about
their symptoms
that's horrible it's also putting people
on a position
where big pharma is the good guy now
yeah
which has never happened never and
especially the the exact same companies
that people were openly criticizing
in the past and and showing pointing out
lawsuits they've lost
for hiding information about test
results
about things that have uh happened
during studies
and these these same people are now
ignoring
any any possible side effects it's it's
nuts so
i mean how do we make it better how do
we know maybe some people i mean
that suppression of data is not the way
you improve a vaccine
the suppression of people's symptoms and
data that is not you've no in anything
it's not how it works
that's how they want it to work because
of trump because if you say
it's just crazy it is crazy even that
hydrochloroquine right that
hydroxychloroquine yeah
hydroxychloroquine that trump was
touting and they were like he's nuts
because he's touting it i didn't know
anything about
uh but then all of a sudden studies came
out that say hey no that actually has
been helping
so now they have we have contrary
contradicting studies right i just
it was a news week i wasn't making it i
didn't pull it out of some crazy
thing it's an establishment mainstream
news thing i'm pretty sure it was
newsweek
and i tweeted it out and i said hey can
we stop now can we stop uh
politicizing medical science can we get
back to just doing medical science again
and asking questions how much damage did
trump do on that one
the one conversation he had maybe do
something like
cleaning something with you so much
damage you do
completely right like uh
you could kill it with lights it's gonna
be a miracle like that one
thing where people like what the [ __ ] is
because he was riffing yes he was
clearly riffing
he didn't prepare for this he probably
just got didn't eaten a [ __ ] double
cheeseburger and he's like
[Laughter]
this he's you know because he's a
salesman he's just a big
bro because he's so divisive like
everyone is still
it's it's almost like do you know like
if you got in a
fight with someone like maybe your
neighbor and then you got in your car
and there was a road incident and you're
like get the [ __ ] out of here
you're already so ramped up yeah because
of the fight you got in with your
neighbor
yeah this is what the whole country's
like that's you're that's a great
analogy that's what it's like it's like
the whole country just got in a fight
with the neighbor like he's putting his
trash can on your lawn
yeah hey you [ __ ] keep them on your own
side you piece of [ __ ]
and then you're in your car [ __ ] and
this is like the whole
country is like at eight out the door
out the door in their car already at
eight and a scale one to ten they're
already ready to go
and so whether it's the vaccine or
whether it's the border wall
or whether it's kids in cages or what
the [ __ ] whatever it is everybody's
so goddamn angry and ready to go and
then you deal with the economic crisis
that
a giant percentage of the country just
went through over the past year and then
losing loved ones to this [ __ ]
disease and
all this chaos and all that and so many
people who
have never experienced like high levels
of adversity
and all of a sudden they're confronted
with it if you've played it safe your
whole life you've really never
done anything risky never taken any
chances you've had a regular life with a
regular job
you play it safe and then all sudden now
you're [ __ ] and you're confronted with
a perhaps deadly disease that might take
you out
and you've got all these other problems
in the world and everybody's like
and they don't have the coping skills
they don't have the ability to handle
these things and that's where we find
ourselves as a country right now
and it's weird because then you have
that with the echo chamber aspect of
social media where everybody's just
looking for
positive reinforcement of their own
ideas and confirmation bias
it's wild catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience